Now it's not very practical to
write down every running time
function exactly, so computer scientists
use various levels of approximation.
For complexity,
we use asymptotic analysis.
I'm going to do a very
brief review here, but
if you haven't seen this idea before,
you should take a few minutes to study
it on your own before
proceeding with the lesson.
We define big O of a function
F to be the set of functions
G where there are numbers C and
big N such that for all little N,
at least as big as big N,
G of N is at most C times F of N.
In other words,
C times F of N is at least G of N for
all sufficiently large N.
Even though we've
defined big O as a set,
we write g(n) = O (f(n)) instead
of using the inclusion sign.
We also say that G is order F.
This definition can be
a little confusing.
But it should feel like the definition
of a limit from your calculus class.
In fact, we can re-state this
condition to say that the ratio
of G over F converges to
a constant under the lim soup.
An example also, helps.
Take this function, g of n is equal
to n squared minus n plus ten.
We can argue that this is order n
squared, by choosing c is equal to one.
And big N equal to ten.
For every little n greater than ten,
N squared,
this red line here, is bigger than
the function g, the blue line.
We also could have chosen
c equal to ten and
big N equal to one again in that case.
The red line, the c times n squared,
is bigger than the function g,
the blue line.
Note that the big O notation does
not have to create a tight bound.
Thus, g(n) is also order n squared,
setting c equal to 1 and
N equal to 3 works for this.